My parents never had much.
They risk everything they had to immigrate
from India to the u s in search of a
better life and when I was born,
they loved me unconditionally.
No matter what happened in my life,
I always knew that I could trust them.
In fact, I first learned what it meant
to trust from my relationship with them.
Trust is the foundation of
every human connection, culture,
community. In fact, our entire
civilization depends on trust.
It's the ability to predict
what others will do.
It governs every interaction we have
with humans. In personal relationships.
Trust means exposing your vulnerabilities
to someone and believing that they
won't take advantage of that openness.
When you first meet someone,
you can't predict where
that relationship will go,
but if you're willing to give them
your trust, you can get to know them,
their hopes and fears,
their wildest dreams in their darkest
secrets and as all that trust compounds
over time,
the benefits of closeness and intimacy
far outweigh the possibility of pain and
betrayal. Part of the human
condition is to make predictions.
We are constantly forecasting ahead by
building internal models of the world
based both on our experiences
and what others tell us.
Then use these to guess
what will happen next.
We trust that people will take
their responsibilities seriously,
that they'll abide by whatever
rules apply to the task at hand.
We trust teachers to educate our children,
chefs to serve a sanitary food
and coworkers to do their part.
We've collectively built systems of
trust all around us to facilitate our
interactions with each other and the
data shows that in countries where people
highly trust each other,
there also tends to be low
levels of income inequality
as well as high levels of
political and economic stability.
So how do we know who to trust?
A 17th century English philosopher named
Thomas Hobbs argued that in order to
maintain civil peace and
social unity in a society,
there needed to be some kind of sovereign
power responsible for protecting the
security of the Commonwealth and granted
absolute authority to ensure the common
defense.
He called this power the Leviathan.
The first Leviathan
was organized religion.
The idea was that if people put all their
trust in God and followed his will on
how to interact with others,
they behaved themselves.
But soon another Leviathan emerged.
The Nation state it offered to handle
the complexities of managing society
through the creation of laws and the
enforcement of those laws be a uniformed
police force. But now we are
witnessing the rise of a new Leviathan,
the network with the rise of the network.
Anyone in the world can communicate
with anyone else and because of that,
we also now have the ability
to trust anyone in the world.
Trust was once an expensive pursuits
in order to convey it. Banks,
elite schools and government offices
were built from luxurious materials to
declare solidity and tradition,
but the network has changed all of that.
Now we're prepared to place our lives
in the hands of people we know nothing
about because of the emergence of network
services that enable to strangers to
trust each other. We share rides
with Uber, stay in homes with Airbnb,
hire workers with upwork.
The list goes on.
These services have codified reputation.
They've built webs of trust.
The number of stars next to someone's
name makes it possible to trust them even
though we've never met them,
but these systems of trust
we've created have been abused.
Many governments across the world have
shown that they can't be held trustworthy.
The series of pro-democracy protests
across the Middle East now as the Arab
spring were hampered when
local governments cut off
the protesters Internet
access. The Chinese government routinely
sensors data from its populous,
which accounts for about a fifth of
the world and even in more developed
countries like the u s trust
in the federal government
is at an all time low as
income inequality continues to rise.
This has led to the rise of the incubator
Trump with his die hard followers
demanding he drained the swamp.
The corporations that have built on the
neutral playing field other web now own
most of our personal data and we've
learned that several of them have breached
our trust in many ways using personal
data and time and time again,
corporate banks have stolen money from
countless people and influence the
direction of entire governments with
the power we've entrusted in them.
The sheer size of these institutions we
built make the situation look hopeless,
competing with the government banking
cartel is illegal and can be severely
punished.
They define monetary policy and our need
to use money that depends on them has
become our straight jacket.
But a few years ago,
a paper was posted in a cryptography
mailing list detailing a system called
bitcoin that could challenge the most
powerful monopolies in the world.
It was the first system to show that it
was possible for two people to exchange
value over the Internet without the
need to trust a third party like a bank.
Bitcoin currently has a market cap of
$80 billion and has remained secure after
all these years.
Soon people started wondering what if the
underlying technology of bitcoin could
be used to remove the need for a
trusted third party. In other areas,
the blockchain,
bitcoin's data structure
and its associated proof of
work algorithm are starting
to be applied to other concepts,
insurance, law, healthcare,
anywhere where a risky amount of
trust is involved can be a space where
blockchain technology can improve the
system by offloading some of the trust
necessary from humans to machines.
For example,
there's a blockchain enabled microgrid
service in Brooklyn that lets individuals
sell their excess solar energy directly
to neighbors without involving a central
utility company.
We can create new organizations like
this that are distributed and autonomous
systems that are open trustless and
meritocratic with humans at the edges and
automation at the center. But last year
we learned something really important,
one of the most popular
blockchain communities,
etherium second only to bitcoin
in market cap. Hard for it.
What that means is after a hacker stole
$60 million worth of their internal
currency,
the community collectively made a
controversial decision to rewind the
blockchain. So the money would
go back to the original owners.
This shocked many people
in the wider community.
Since one of the core character juristics
of a blockchain is it's ability to
remain immutable.
The hard fork proved that blockchains
are not in fact immutable and it also
proves something much more significant
that the blockchain is not in fact a
trustless system.
Yes,
we don't have to trust any one
party like a bank to utilize it,
but we do trust three parties. When
you hold cryptocurrency in your wallet,
you are trusting the miners to secure
the network and validate transactions,
the developers to maintain and improve
the code and the users to use the
platform.
So you're not trusting one party,
you're trusting the entire
community. Blockchains don't
offer a trustless system,
but rather a reassignment of trust
amongst many parties instead of one.
The more distributed the trustees,
the more the risk of fraud decreases.
So instead of building systems
that try to eliminate trust,
maybe we should build systems that
strengthened it. Not more trust, less,
but more trust fall. Imagine apps that
are run by the community that uses them.
That means a writer and a driver not
eating a for profit third party to help
them find and trust each other or a
consumer owning their own demographic
profile and choosing what to disclose
to service providers in exchange for
economic value.
So wild trust is necessary in every
interaction we have with humans.
There are many cases where minimizing it
is beneficial and we can use blockchain
technology to do that,
but the need to trust won't go away.
And that's okay.
We can't escape human reliance as
fallible and imperfect as we are.
There will always be some risk involved
in our interaction with humans.
And the higher the risk,
the higher the reward.
As we build better systems that nurture
and nourish trust will be able to extend
our capabilities in every
way by augmenting our
intelligence with the power of
the web becoming ever more
connected with each other.
And when I think back to the dreams
my dad had from me as a child,
or the ones that all that eager young
developers I've met have for success,
or the ones I have in my
most intimate relationships,
I realized that trust can be the bridge
between where we are now and where we
all want to be home.
Okay.
Hey guys,
hope you liked the video.
The winter of last week's coding
challenge is Zacharias Bowler.
Saccharides created a decentralized
machine learning journal using IPFS.
So awesome. I've already
bookmarked this for my own use.
He's got some great documentation too, so
definitely check it out. Very well done.
And the runner up is a new guitar who
created a decentralized Dropbox on IPFS.
Very ambitious.